what's up everyone here we are again
with another top 10 list this time how
about something a bit more evil they say
first impressions are everything that
holds even truer for so many of the
compelling villains in anime
maybe it's the Display of power or just
the sheer intimidation factor these
select 10 have made their mark the
moment they appeared on screen
regardless of what anyone might think so
today Vinnie 2 presents the top 10 of
villain introductions in anime let's
begin the countdown
we opened this list with beast Titans
introduction season 2 of attack on Titan
officially introduces us to the beast
Titan now by now you should be experts
at distinguishing Titans that are
important to the plot from unnamed
fodder apparently me K Zacharias isn't
as he mistakes the beast Titan for a
run-of-the-mill abnormal that mistake
proves costly as he experiences
firsthand the fearsome ability of the
beast Titan what happens next is more
surprising as the beast Titan shows the
capability to command other Titans he
speaks and tries to interrogate the
helpless human about the mobility gears
finding those satisfying answer he
relents and allows the Titans to devour
their victim
next we have cast as introduction faith
zeroes caster is arguably one of the
creepier and more sinister servants in
the faith stay nighttime light of course
a grand villain like him deserves
nothing less than what the face zero
anime gave him instead of being cool or
amazing like most servants caster is
nothing short of chilling in a series
that prides itself on gray morality
caster provides that one character the
viewers can immediately latch on to as
the bad guy that one irredeemable at
least in this series villain to root
against on another note the magnificent
and chilling introduction of caster
Andriano scare contrast to a lot of the
absurd scenes that feature this master
servant Jerome it's a match made in
heaven or hell for that matter
[Music]
next up is Mary Webb's introduction in
the 8th spot is it safe to say that the
Chimera ant are elevated hunter hunter
to the upper echelon of shown in anime
much of it has to do with the
development of Miriam and the
philosophical questions raised
throughout the journey of this
antagonist it goes without saying that
the development would have been as
impactful if the introduction wasn't up
to par at the moment of Mehrunes
premature birth everyone immediately saw
how he'd factor into the story when his
mother feels him trying to come out she
screams that it's too soon and then he
literally tells her to shut up and
forcibly rips himself out of his sack
when Peggy rushes to help her
Marilyn cuts him down with a whip of his
tail pretty disturbing and chilling aim
but what better way to showcase his
initial characterization than the
circumstances surrounding his birth
[Music]
now we take a look at Goku black the
seventh entry on the list truth be told
the idea of an evil Goku has been played
around for a while now
the in fanfiction or even official
characters like turell's I doubt any of
them would have had the impactful
introduction the Goku black got with the
scene of him staring down trunks from
afar still sticking in the back of my
mind now I know a lot of people were
lukewarm or even cautious at the idea of
an evil Goku at first but the villains
core introduction and his eventual
development gradually won many DBZ fans
over
sure cause my leaking
tomorrow here
[Music]
how could any Jojo fan forget the pillar
men's introduction that sixth on the
list
the pillar men awakenings one of the
more bizarre and gripping scenes in
battle tendency and that's saying
something a more lighthearted entry in
the Jojo series battle tendency suddenly
gets far more serious with the
introduction of this group of villains
WaMu awakens by suddenly launching an
attack on the Nazis as he breaks out of
his seal he does what a judge of
character does posing before turning
serious and crushing what feeble
resistance the Nazis gave off he linked
the Nazis together in order to kill them
more easily giving one more look at his
handiwork he then awakens the rest of
his kin the world trembles at the power
of the pillar men
[Music]
well
Smith on the list is Luo Liang fifth
place is someone who's no stranger to
these lists Liu Lang from sword of the
stranger finds his way into another list
with his amazing introduction like the
wolf he's named after Luo Liang easily
tears through the bandits like the
feeble prey they are with superior speed
strength and tactics of full display the
massacre only further highlights what
awaits our protagonists at the climax of
the movie you mean that's what they have
to be just what do they have to pull out
of their arsenal in order to stand a
chance against this beast only one way
to find out and that's to watch the
sword of the stranger
number four on the list is overhaul
overhauls definitely one of the coolest
villains in my hero academia even though
we seem at the end of season 3 his
formal introduction is when he comes
face to face with the league of villains
you might expect a new face to be taken
aback by The Hideout the nastiest
villains left in the post all my world
but not overhaul instead he criticizes
shigaraki and the rest of the league no
he's not interested in joining the
league in their quest to crown shigaraki
the next ruler of the world overhaul
turns the tables and urges them to join
him instead a melee between villains
commences and showing how little he
cares for the lives of his subordinates
talk about some good old evil versus
evil got a love pissing contest between
these villains they're so fun to watch
[Music]
Princessa
[Music]
Oh Monica
what a way to make an entrance stepping
over one of the main characters in
turning the three-on-one battle around
to his advantage that's what this
monster of a swordsman does in his anime
debut anime only fans watching that
scene probably thought who is this
strange masked man without knowing that
they're already looking at the most
overpowered villain in the Gintama
universe with ginto keys help bird Sora
is eventually forced back only to reveal
a face that would traumatize ginto key
for quite some time
he also displays his regenerative powers
giving our heroes a first glimpse of
that terrifying ability that would be
more than tough to overcome
[Music]
Jake told okok to
water Datsun or kinder and talk it up we
still poured it
[Music]
career by even she thought Voss tunnel
de kado is a runner-up placing second on
this top 10 list kaido's introduction in
one-pieces anime is simplistic the huge
beast pirate jumps off a sky island
looking for a place to die unfortunately
for him he survives the fall and lands
on an island surrounded by pirates way
out of his league you could guess what
happened right after to those poor
pirates caught you what makes his
introduction extra special is the
narration and the music while he
descends from the sky nothing else can
be heard but a long narration of his
past deeds going along with ominous
music with line after line of hype you
can see how powerful this humongous
villain is nothing better than having
narration and serious music hyping up
your first appearance
cinnabar somata Marriott Okinawa
saku-dono keidel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we end the list with who else but mother
er how many of these lists has mother er
appeared in perhaps it's a testament to
how awesome he is in the grand scheme of
things he really deserves to have the
role of being the ultimate villain
instead of being hijacked by Kaguya yeah
I said it if you've been following other
videos on this channel this moment
doesn't need any introduction so for now
I'll let you relive the moment once more
with the video come on I'm sure some of
you forgot who you should be cheering
for in that fight anyone seeing a
one-man army fight like that would
surely be caught in the moment and
struck with awe at the power exhibited
by the bad guy this moment is the key
moment that confirmed that Martha is the
real deal this is it one of the
strongest villains that our heroes have
to overcome
so we come to the end those are my top
10 villain introductions in anime what
do you think of them have you got anyone
else to suggest perhaps you would have
write the entries a bit differently I'm
listening if you enjoyed the video like
share and subscribe also if you'd like
to support the channel please consider
joining the channel membership are
really appreciated
I'll see you next time on Vinnie tube
[Music]